Now we're going to talk about something that's pretty important in practice,
and that's creating software that can be tested effectively.
And we're going to start off with things
that are kind of maybe a little bit fuzzy and unquantifiable.
And we'll get towards more very specific
recommendations a little bit later.
And so I'm going to start off with some sort of generic
recommendations, and first, it's to write clean code,
and, of course, we all know that's pretty much impossible.
So when it's not possible to write clean code in the first place,
we need to refactor code whenever necessary.
So third, of any software module that we're writing,
we should always be able to clearly describe
what it is that this module does
and exactly how it interacts with other code.
If we find ourselves in a situation where we can't
clearly describe all of the dependencies
that our module has with other modules in the system,
then we're probably in a situation where we've
created software that can't be tested effectively.
Code should never have any more threads
than it absolutely needs to get its work done.
The software should not be a swamp of global variables.
Global variables make software really hard to test,
because global variables are implicitly inputs
to any software that reads the global variables.
And so, in addition to testing software
on its explicit inputs, if we have a lot of
global variables, we're going to be forced to test
a lot of values of those, and this
can really make testing difficult.  Our code--
and this applies probably more to C and C++
and Java than to Python--shouldn't be a soup
of references and pointers, because these are another way
to create unintentional connections between different parts of the code,
breaking modularity and again making it
really hard to test our code.
Most of the time, the modules that we'll create
should have unit tests, and when applicable--
that is to say when our modules are interfacing
with other modules that might fail--
we should add support for fault injection.
Finally, testable software often contains
a large number of assertions,
and so now we're going to expand on that topic.